a regional vote but also a test for
india's prime minister and his governing
bjp party narendra modi stands accused
of being divisive so how will these
state elections shape his political
future and what will that mean for
democracy in india this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm kim
vanell
millions of people in india will be
voting in state elections this week and
until march the 7th ballots will be cast
across five states among them the most
populous uttar pradesh results there are
seen as a referendum on prime minister
narendra modi and his governing bjp
party indicating how people may vote
during the next national elections
opposition parties are trying to
capitalize on the bjp's decline in
popularity caused by three farming laws
that triggered protests for more than a
year have nibital sent us this report
from uttar pradesh
we're outside a polling station in
amroha in uttar pradesh where people are
lining up to cast their vote in india's
biggest state election now uttar pradesh
is home to more than 200 million people
and sends the highest number of members
to india's parliament and therefore has
an outsized importance in india's
political landscape this election is
widely seen as a test of prime minister
narendra modi's popularity now this is
an agrarian state which backed the bjp
overwhelmingly in 2017 but since then
support among farmers has dwindled for
one many of them participated in that
year-long agitation against the three
farm laws they said favored big
corporations now those laws were
eventually revoked by the prime minister
because of these upcoming elections
but many farmers have continued to
protest over unmet demands other
financial issues like price rise and
unemployment are also playing out in
these polls it's not just pradesh four
other states in india are also holding
elections this month results for all
will be out on march 10. analysts say
that the bjp does uh continue to be a
favorite and will watch out for the
victory margin in the state of uttar
pradesh i'm partner for inside story
okay we'll begin our discussion in a
moment but first let's bring you up to
date with india's journey so far under
narendra modi and the hindu nationalist
bjp
modi became prime minister with an
historic landslide victory in national
general elections in 2014.
he was soon accused of trying to silence
opposition after activists and
journalists critical of the government
began being arrested
in 2019 modi was re-elected he then
imposed a widespread crackdown and a
lockdown on the disputed region of
kashmir and revoked its semi-autonomous
status that same year protests erupted
nationwide after modi enacted a
controversial citizenship law that
provided citizenship for religious
minorities but excluded muslims
in 2020 farming reform law was passed it
prompted months long peaceful protests
and strikes which sometimes turned
violent in recent months the bjp has
been accused of allowing hate speech
against muslims and its rallies and
polarizing the country last january bjp
controlled states began imposing a ban
on religious headscarves worn by muslims
in schools
[Applause]
all right let's bring in our guests in
new delhi we have surhanshu matal a
politician and senior leader in the
baharetiya janata party the bjp in kochi
tulsi
k raj a lawyer at the supreme court of
india and kerala high court and in
lucknow fatima khan a journalist at the
quint thank you very much for joining us
warm welcome to the program i'd like to
start with you sudhanshu matal
if these elections are a referendum on
narendra modi who's halfway through his
term and on the ruling bjp of which you
are apart how do you feel it's going to
go
yeah i don't think it's a referendum on
mr narendra modi he's ruling the country
he's the prime
minister this is a referendum on the
rule of mr
aditya yogi adetanath yogi who's the
chief minister of that state
who was elected who has been at the helm
of affairs for the last five years
so to call it a referendum on
is an exaggeration
up is a very very critical state
the population of u.p is more than uh
225 million people which is huge and it
actually accounts for one-sixth of the
number of parliament seats so yes it's
very critical
but the critical issue this time before
people when they make the choices is
the earlier government led by atletico
of a party called samadhi
it it is the
uh manifestation of the criminality
perpetrated by a section of people
with official patronage
that is what people saw for the last
five years
and that is when they chose and decided
to offer bjp
the reason was that one particular
religious community and one particular
caste
had dominance over the law and order
machinery there so every police station
had a majority of these people
you could not file cases against them
their return ran large
they would abduct people they would
you know
take
just entered the fields and
take over the land
claiming their ownership
that the women were not saved anybody
could be abducted or people could be
beaten up at the mercy
so that fearful environment necessitated
the people to opt for a government which
will bring peace and tranquility and
which will eliminate the mafia raj okay
the rule of the mafia the rule of the
criminals i hear i hear what you're
saying
i hear what you're saying and i just
want to uh clarify for our international
audience when we talk about up we talk
about we're talking about uttar pradesh
i'd like to cross over to you just for
your response um khan obviously you're a
journalist you're covering the run-up to
these elections do you think that these
are uh
a litmus test for the prime minister
i do think it is a litmus test for the
bjp as a whole you know these elections
they come right on the heels of a number
of historic events that have taken place
in the country in the last couple of
years alone the farmers protest that you
mentioned 13-month long farmer's protest
where several farmers from different
parts of north india they sat at the
peripheries of the national capital
protesting against the bjp remember the
farmers um had voted in a huge chunk a
huge majority of farmers had voted for
the bjp in the previous elections as
well as the 2019 polls so for the
farmers to uh sit and mobilize
themselves against the pgp was a huge
matter of course we cannot forget the
kovid second wave uh which ravaged
through multiple states uttar pradesh
alone saw multiple deaths multiple
casualties because of a complete
infrastructure collapse under the bjp
and at that time of course it was being
said that if nothing this will be the
downfall of the bjp
of course i have been covering these
elections for the last two months now
i've been on the field um and i can tell
you the pgp does continue to remain
hugely hugely popular uh notwithstanding
of course the fact that there are people
who continue to have their grievances so
ultimately this if i have to put it
simplistically i'd say that it is a
matter of choice that the voters have to
take between you know the appeal of
hindutva the brand of hindus what the
prime minister modi and the bjp have
popularized across the country versus
more material issues that they might
have faced whether vis-a-vis
with the farm laws or the covet wave or
just generally price rise
infrastructural issues
anything that you would consider in any
other scenario would be enough reason to
bring down a government i'd like to
cross over to kochie and i do see you
there as well mr mattel we will come
back to you shortly but first i'd like
to go to
uh tulsi raj
uh in kochi
we spoke there about some of the issues
at play you've written about
hate speech and
there is rising hindu nationalist
sentiment across the across the country
right there have been protests in one
state about the decision to ban the
wearing of the muslim headscarf in
educational settings
so you believe the role of the courts is
more important than ever talk us through
that and what your assessment is
sure thank you so much for the question
and congratulations
speaking and organizing a debate on a
very important issue which uh which in
fact the world is watching
um i would in fact think that the
islamophobia that is launched by the
right-wing government which is led by
modi has been widespread it's been also
incremental if we look at how the
nature of islamophobia emerged we will
see that in the beginning the attempt
was to consider or treat muslims as
second-class citizens so that's what we
have seen with the citizenship amendment
act in 2019
by which they said that citizenship will
be extended to all communities outside
india except for muslims muslims were
ineligible to apply for citizenship in
the country therefore we saw an
incremental process of
converting them converting actual
citizens
to second-class citizenship and from
that we have we have come to a situation
where there is an open call for genocide
against muslims and that's precisely
what happened in haridwar in indian city
in december that that a group of
so-called saints assembled and they said
that india should be a hindu state and
they said that whatever should be done
in the in in their capacity to transform
india into a hindu state and they were
in fact there were references made to
the genocide that occurred in in myanmar
against india refugees so this is the
political context in which we are
talking about and this is a very
scary and and very intimidating
social political context for how
how does the law deal with that kind of
rhetoric
yes
it's been quite interesting to see that
the law and order situation in india in
in video states has been has been
dealing it with it quite poorly
uh for example the the genocide call
which was made in december there was no
registration of fir which is called
which is essentially the first
information report which is which means
the registering of a crime that is the
initial registering of a crime by the
police that has not happened until
recent calls were were done and there
was an enormous public pressure on the
police to actually register a crime and
even while registering the crime
important provisions of the indian penal
code were left out of this of this
registration and only very few
provisions were actually charged against
the saints who in fact made an open call
for genocide okay and coming back to
your quest as to how the constitutional
courts were dealing with with it i would
think that uh the idea of a
constitutional court is to essentially
be counter majoritarian to resist these
kind of majoritarian atrocities against
the minorities and i do not think that
the indian supreme court or the high
courts in the country has been dealing
quite actively with it they've been
adopting very broadly of course is a
very broad generalizing statement
they've been dealing with it with it
quite passively and quite indifferently
and many occasions we've seen courts
taking blankly uh the side of the
executive
all right sudanshi mattel i can see you
wanting to jump in there go ahead
it's the most vicious and untruthful
statement i've ever heard
let me start with the first
the citizen amendment act
here it says it denies the muslims
citizenship of this country
you are completely wrong and untrue
for the simple reason this act was
enacted for protecting the minorities of
theocratic states
which have been persecuted and compelled
to leave their countries now which are
the theocratic states pakistan is a
theocratic state which has got a muslim
majority
the persecution of the religious
minorities of pakistan
when they come to india we said we will
protect them afghanistan when they come
to india we said we will protect them so
it is all states which are theocratic
states ruled by a majority which happens
to be muslims
and there the religious minorities when
persecuted and when they come to india
including bangladesh
that is when they are given the
citizenship now
if a majority
if a member of a majority of a
theocratic state comes and seeks uh
citizenship is he religiously persecuted
no
so this is giving citizenship to
religiously persecuted minorities okay
by a theocratic story i hear you what i
don't want to do what i don't want to do
is jump into a retrospective
of of that issue of the time because
what we're talking about is how this was
received by the indian population
and how that is going to translate into
the elections that is what we want to
talk about so so let's let's talk about
the elections
the rhetoric which you heard from the
previous two uh speakers
has been to sow hatred among religious
communities saying
muslims are angry with the
hindu-dominated state
you will realize that this state has not
discriminated against the hindus or the
muslims
show me one example where the government
of the day
has said this is what is available to a
religious uh majority and this is not
what is available to a religious
minority i think nothing at all i think
everybody here agrees with the poll
seems to agree with polarization but i
can see over in uh luck now
you're wanting to jump in and i think
it's crucial that we that we ensure
everybody has the right of reply and
that we we keep this even please go
ahead fedomakan in lucknow
yes
yes a number of things for one i quickly
like to address that when you talk about
caam mr mitchell has gone on and on
about the number of states uh whose
religiously persecuted minorities would
be allowed citizenship in india i'd like
to ask him what about rohit india
muslims myanmar is also neighborhood
indian muslims they allow citizenship in
the country uh secondly uh the fact that
we can even i don't think it's even
it even merits a debate at this point of
time whether or not you get it runs a
majoritarian government i think it is a
given i think bjp office bearers who i
speak to on the daily basis have
acknowledged it in so many words just to
give you one example he was asking for
an example and i'll give you one yogurt
the chief minister
in his in his election rallies over and
over again he's used
to explicitly say that he will bring in
hindu rashtra uh meaning a hindu nation
he's explicitly said that there's a
fight between 80 percent versus 20
percent a dog whistle against muslim
minorities he's explicitly said that so
far up has only had a government that is
focused on kubristan
is urdu for graveyard he's repeatedly
used dog whistle anti-muslim dog whistle
over and over again in so many words he
will not deny it so i have no i do not
understand why mr mitchell stands here
tonight and denies it okay second of all
i think just going but going back on the
elections i think it is important to
understand that communalism and hate
have been normalized in this state and
if your gaza comes back to power and
there is a huge possibility that he will
i will not deny the fact that he
continues to be hugely popular among the
masters here and if he does come back to
power here it will be a signal sent out
to several other states in the country
that this kind of politics is acceptable
normalized and will be celebrated
i want to come over to you
has the opposition
uh those in opposition to the bjp have
they capitalized on
you know some of the frustrations that
might be there
it's a important question at that and i
think the opposition unfortunately has
not been able to consolidate effectively
against the against the right-wing
hindu rhetoric that that is being pushed
forward and i think there is
considerable potential for the
opposition parties in in the country to
come together and form coalitions in all
the five states in which upcoming
elections and in fact polls have begun
in in some of them and there is a
tremendous potential for that but
unfortunately i would think that the the
potent the potential is not being fully
made use of including by the congress
party which in fact is the largest uh
oppositional
party in the in the national scenario
and that is in fact one of the reasons
why the bjp and and the allies including
the rss are able to come forward and are
able to push the the rhetoric of hate uh
in the country it is partly it is the
failure of the of the opposition and
partly it is the failure of the populace
i think a country where where there has
been quite quite a large amount of
socioeconomic backwardness quite a large
amount of illiteracy is unable to i
think uh to a great extent see that the
dangers of a hindu majority a party
which
and and the kind of principles they're
trying to so and
they're they're somewhat being blinded
by by the promise of development by the
promise of betterment and and and by the
promise of projecting india to be one of
the world leading countries of economy
the promises of
of a trillion economy when india is
still remains uh according to oxfam and
other findings remains as one of the
most unequal countries in the world but
where there is so much inequality that
thrives uh the the attempt is to sort of
hide that the attempt is to not address
these socio-economic inequalities okay
the attempt is rather to uh project
india as a leading world uh economy
which which it uh clearly is not okay i
i i want to come back over to um
sudanshi matal in new delhi i could see
you wanted to get in there um i would
like your response to what we've heard
earlier and i'd also like to ask you
about the the issue of the agricultural
reforms which as we've we've talked
about before sparks year-long protests
i mean uttar pradesh has a large rural
population right so how is that going to
play do you think for the bjp
first the
hate rhetoric
casting aspersions on the people of this
state
saying they are not
educated enough to differentiate i think
it is
rather
derogatory to people of uttar pradesh
please don't do it
if there is a narrative which any
political party
unleashes
the people of the state have wisdom to
understand
what is good for them and what is not
good for them see people of this country
vote for their future
they vote for what they believe
is beneficial to them and they've never
voted wrong
they voted against bjp at places we lost
so many elections when they felt that
the alternatives are better attentive so
now to say that if bjp wins then the
people of that state
are uneducated and so they cannot
differentiate this is this is absolutely
wrong unacceptable and please do not
denigrate the people
you just said your lady you just said
you just said the same thing all right
no i didn't know anyway now let me come
down
let me come down to the issue let me
come down to the issue of
agriculture reforms
it was a very ambitious program of this
government
to do agriculture reforms which would be
beneficial to the farmers of this
country because this country
has a huge population of agriculture in
fact that's the primary
occupation of this country
now there are miscommunications and
there are communications which
led people to believe that these are
inadequate laws which may not be good
for them
so after trying to persuade the people
when it was seen that they are not
getting persuaded and the misgivings
continue pivot rule that's it
now uttar pradesh has a lot a lot of
huge agricultural populations so is
every part of this country
because as i said that's the primary
occupation of people of
of of india
uttar pradesh education was largely
confined to people in the western uk
and there was a particular community
which was particularly incised because
of this because it had its bearing in
the politics of haryana also
now this community has also seen the
subsequent events after the withdrawal
and when the results will be out you
know i'm at least happy that both the
panelists here are conceding
that in democracy the people have more
faith on bjp and that's why bjp is
likely to win okay thank you for that
anybody if we are going to win we are
not going to win because we we delivered
hate speeches we are going to one
because people thought future is most
secured with us as you said that is good
for their future as you say people will
give their opinions at the polls and
that is the point of elections i'd like
to cross back over to
uh to luck now fatima khan i could see
you wanted to get in there was this
something you wanted to add
i think i just want to make it very
clear that uh individuals make the
choices that they didn't fit
and no one here will come and ever
questioned those choices uh in terms of
whether or not they were made because
they're educated or not educated but
everyone has full right to analyze why
those choices were made in terms of what
was the impetus for them uh i just now
all they have been on the field
reporting i have met people who lost
their immediate family members their
husband their son their parents to code
secondhand and i had met them earlier at
the peak of the second wave too and they
had in so many words said that they're
so angry they're so upset even now they
maintain that they're hugely hugely
disappointed with the government but
they some of them say that we'll still
continue to vote for the bjp for so and
so reasons for many reasons being okay
you know what this is a hindutva
government this is a in the majoritarian
government and we identify as in the
majoritarian people and we identify with
that brand of politics and so we'll vote
for them and that is the choice those
individual voters are making so i think
no one's here being judgmental about
individual voters but we will call a
state foreign um and i hope no one has a
problem with that
all right uh i'd like to come over back
together
can i just say something about the
corvette very quickly because we are
running out of time very quickly
covet is a phenomena which is a global
phenomena
and this global phenomena played havoc
with the lives of people all across the
world
not just uttar pradesh
not only the system collapsed in utah
they should collapse everywhere but
hats off to the governments of the
country hats off to the people of this
country that they fought back with their
inadequacy when it came to vaccination
they ensured that we have such a huge
vaccination program that when this wave
came this time look at the collateral
damage
but
just just negligible so it is not how
you were caught by surprise because the
world was caught by surprise but once
you got aware of what is happening how
you fought back you fought back with
such determination that i salute the
people of this country i salute the
governments the governments include
non-bgp governments also so don't don't
say things which do not merit a logical
uh
endorsement and as you say this is a
pandemic that has affected the entire
world and uh nations populations around
the world are voting on their leaders
responses which i'm sure will be in in
people's minds at these state elections
we will have to leave it there for time
thank you to all of our guests guests
sadhanshu mithal tusi keraj and
and thank you for watching you can see
the program again anytime by visiting
our website al jazeera.com and for
further discussion go to our facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
aj inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from me kim vanell and
the whole team here in doha bye for now
[Music]
you